on our right now mercedes-benz vans
phone line is the head coach of the
university of houston
basketball team that just bounced
illinois
from the tournament and now houston's
next up opponent is arizona and kind
enough to call in after that win over
illinois and ahead of this huge wheat
sweet 16 matchup against the number one
seed in the south is head coach kelvin
sampson how are you coach
i'm good rich thanks for having me on
how are you doing i'm doing fine uh you
know we're on peacock we're on sirius xm
radio and we're on uh terrestrial radio
so i need you to paint the word picture
for me i really never start uh
interviews out this way so with all due
respect i asked the question do you have
your shirt on right now
you have your shirt on
uh to the benefit of everybody on the
bus we're driving on to san antonio
right now
ah okay so the answer is yes
you do have your shirt on right now how
many people did you hear
from uh after we saw your
shirts off celebration with your
your team uh
you know i did to my phone uh until
we're on the bus to get back i think i
had uh 300 some tech
and at that point you're just
happy for emotion i bet i bet so and and
um
your your kids must have loved that they
must have absolutely
yeah
obviously something like that cannot be
uh planned um
a couple years ago we we beat ohio state
to go to the sweet 16
that was the year we lost to kentucky
but i it was a very similar situation
back then though i was wearing a shirt
and tie
and as soon as i walked in i just got
blasted with the uh
with the water shower the uh
gatorade cooler and
then the bottles and the squirt bottles
and all that
and i said well when i turned the corner
i saw it was coming and i said what the
hell you know let's dive in there just
take it like a man i took my shirt off
for some dog reason
well i it looks like you've been working
out i'll be honest with you i'd like to
know what your workout regimen is coach
uh
just
trying to stay up with these 18 to 20
year olds outside there walking around a
little bit
i bet so let's let's get into the uh the
joy of it and obviously winning a
tournament game is
something you don't take for granted um
but your team is went to the final four
last year
and you lost two crucial members of that
final four team due to injury in
december
uh your guards marcus sasser and tremont
mark you lost those guys what did what
what was the feeling around your team in
december when they those guys went down
coach
well i i think um
we played texas state
on the 22nd that morning uh jemon mark
who who has a huge play uh last year
against rutgers on our way to the uh
sweet 16.
he had surgery uh for torn late labrum
and we knew he would be out six to eight
months
but that night we uh the night the game
we played against texas state marcus
sasser who was uh clearly our best
player he's having a great year
um
broke his foot and i didn't find out
until the next morning
we had two days uh two day break from
christmas to 23rd 24th we were coming
back to practice the 20 evening at the
25th
so when i got the news
my trainer called and said coach you sit
down that's usually not that's
not what you want to hear
i said
i said what i said well uh what is it he
said marcus uh
uh
fractured the set the metatarsal on his
left foot
then i said well what's what's the
prognosis uh
he's gonna have to have surgery
and then still holding out hope i said
was he done for a year
i just needed to hear it black and white
and um and i think from there my mind
just started racing i know i just lost
tremont and i've lost marcus that same
game kyler evers had a great two strain
of his left ankle i knew we'd have him
for a couple of weeks so
at that point i was just counting bodies
rich to see how many we had if we could
uh had i had three guards left in the
program
but you know we just say the moment you
know we uh we talk about just be where
your feet are
our next game was at temple we tried to
figure out how to beat temple and
and then each game by itself just uh
every game became
um our season
we really couldn't plan ahead because we
had to figure out how we're going to win
the game and i think that's important
for our kids to to have something to
believe in what's the plan coach
you know how what do you want us to do
and
you know as the head coach who's still
responsible for that um
and we had josh carlton the big kid that
transferred from uconn and
uh we're fortunate to have tajay moore
the athletic kid to transfer from cal
state bakersfield we just gave everybody
a new role and i told them just be all
confidence in your role if you do that
we'll be fine
and now here you are on the uh on the
bus
to
san antonio
after winning two uh in your
first uh go round here in this
tournament um so i imagine you know when
you're taking on arizona
there there might be a nice home court
advantage potentially in that uh in that
arena coach particularly you know we we
plan a beautiful uh newly remodeled
fertitta center
uh i think our first game was in 2018
but it's a beautiful beautiful
arena
and so we're going to try to make uh the
a t and t center where the spurs play uh
for t the south
but joe when the breakfast came out rich
i i you know you kind of peek
ahead a little bit okay whoever comes
out of this bracket
uh will move to the regional finals and
that'll be in san antonio i said well
that will be nice then i quickly went
right back to alabama birmingham right
but now but now that we're here you know
it's uh it's awesome you know it's uh
you know in some ways with this team
everything we're doing is gravy in a lot
of ways you know them would have ever
thought would have make make the
tournament after we lost those two guys
you know this team's just been
phenomenal these are good players now
we're winning because we have good
players now we don't have a lot of them
but
once we have
uh we fight fatigue we fight foul
trouble
but uh kyler edwards jamal shed tajay
more that's a really good back court
courts
fabian white jr has been phenomenal in
his figure i had acl surgery and missed
most of the year last year
josh carlton we didn't know
what to expect but we thought he was a
good player and that we could develop
him and
he's he's uh been better than we
imagined um
uh our bench has been he's young we have
two freshmen and uh junior off the bench
but
those kids play hard i i think that's
what we do we have to make up for some
things we don't have with with our
effort and our tenacity and uh because
we have great kids uh they do it so
um there's no magic here we have good
players and uh they fought into our
system and uh i appreciate every one of
them calvin sampson here on the rich
edson show on the bus to san antonio uh
with the university of houston cougars
getting set to take on arizona that must
have been a late night for you you must
have been like the rest of america on
the edge of a seat with a terrific
basketball game between arizona and tcu
right to see what you're gonna play next
is that what you guys did
that night yeah we were in um
after the illinois game we flew back
um
to houston and uh i actually got back in
time to watch uh the game and i was
impressed with both teams i i didn't
know who was going to win this game was
going back and forth but
um
the thing that stands out
for me
about arizona is their size
you know koloko's seven foot plus
tabalis
611 uh then they bring balo up to ben's
seventh foot you know we we have josh
carlton
who's six ten then we our backup
center's about six seven and
you know we have two four men about six
seven so
um
you know they they're gonna have a size
size advantage
and that's uh that will be a factor
around the rim uh rim protection and
rebounding both ends um
but you know their star is massive i
mean he's easy elite uh high lottery
tape
uh scores at all three levels
takes over a game he's got that clutch
gene as uh tommy lloyd said
um all their guards i mean they're
that's that team is really well well put
together
i can't i can't tell you how impressive
uh a job that tommy's done this time
last year is the assistant that comes
back
now he's got a team that um that can win
it i mean they can win it all
and he's got jason terry's kid does that
make you feel old too
coach
you know um
my first win in the ncaa tournament
against arizona when they had jason
terry and
richard jefferson i think that was 1999.
so
uh when i look out there and see jason
it's this kid i guess in some ways will
have come full circle yeah but that's
when you take off your shirt and you're
like yeah look at me now
you know what i mean like that's when
you go full circle there you know what i
mean come on yeah yeah
yeah full circle um my wife asked me was
uh was i it was did i think i was at a
frat party or something
well what if you beat arizona well you
got a slip and slide you're gonna have
that going on get there get that going
on
right if we beat arizona uh i don't know
what i'll do
i have to figure something out
coach thanks for the time have a safe
rest of your uh your bus trip really
appreciate you calling into the show uh
when you do right in the middle of the
tournament i know you got you're on the
bus but that's when uh that's when good
moments can happen for you and your team
in bonding so i appreciate you taking
some time to call thank you
okay thanks rich thanks having me on you
got it good luck against arizona that's
kelvin sampson
how about that his first ncaa tournament
win was against arizona and jason terry
and now he's taking on terry's kid in a
sweet 16 game life is wild by the way
how crazy would that have been if it was
houston versus tcu and san antonio on a
sweet 16. right
how nuts would that have been
home games for everybody that'd been
insane
oh instead it's arizona hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here